but we begin this half-hour with the
renewed debate over gun laws following
Wednesday's mass shooting at a Florida
high school demonstrators gathered
outside the Virginia headquarters of the
National Rifle Association last night
while the assault rifle used by
suspected shooter Nicholas Cruz was
legally purchased and required a
five-day waiting period some want to see
future sales of the gun stopped as
Adriana Diaz reports that includes some
who are gun owners themselves how many
bullets can that gun shoot in a minute
in a minute it'll shoot as fast as you
can pull the trigger modiji cos guns
store is a mile from the school where a
gunman killed 17 people with an ar-15
what are you feeling that it was
unnecessary to lose all those knife but
he says the gun isn't the problem
they call him assault rifles they don't
call a truck in a salt truck when when
someone runs over a whole bunch of
people on the Westside Highway try to
ban all trucks if I walked into this
store and I wanted to buy an ar-15 what
would be the process how quickly could I
get one you can fill this form up we put
your information if you are a law
abiding citizen you're not a criminal
that we can sell you that gun how
quickly would that process take the
whole process can take no more than 15
minutes and I would walk out of here
with an ar-15
if you have a concealed Ison more than a
thousand people created a see of
candlelight at a vigil Thursday night
honoring the victims Glenn and Angela
goad were there their 14 year old
daughter goes to the school I think
there is absolutely zero need for an
assault rifle in this country the
registered Republicans say this shooting
has changed their view on guns I have
friends who are avid hunters and gunman
and my friends who've probably never
owned a gun like me but I think for me
personally it's time to take a position
they want assault rifles banned and more
security and mental health funding for
schools I'm embarrassed as a father and
as an American that it took this event
to make me have emotion about this
because the children of Sandy Hook were
just as important as the children
parkland he says he never wants to
the despair he felt Wednesday I it was
please don't let me lose this child and
today seventeen families don't get to
say that the couple told us their
neighbors are now holding meetings to
discuss ways to bring change a measure
this store has taken since day one is to
only sell firearms to people 21 or older
for CBS this morning Saturday Adriana
Diaz Coral Springs Florida